[Music]
and a castle culture news submitted by
sleeping dolls online nanny shaming has
sparked an up war with babysitters and
mommy group nanny shaming nanny shaming
oh like if you have a nanny they're like
you can't raise your own kids
no so I know what this is this is hot
nannies and [ __ ] hot nannies yeah it
makes me too hard yeah I'm not gonna let
your 22 year old fine ass in my house
with my husband into my family
infiltrate my family [ __ ] my husband
with the Rockies [ __ ] that sounds like
personal issues buzz and good guesses
though every that was a big extreme when
both parents are at work then the nanny
nanny's no name oh and then my husband
calls out sick and he needs the suck oh
I'm sorry manifesting a terrible future
for you I just have to let you know
redirect your energy please anyway so
this couple a lovely couple they're a
married couple and between 11:00 p.m.
and midnight on June 21st
they received a flurry of emails about
their nanny being the centerpiece of
this Facebook mom group 18,000 members
of NYC moms of Upper East Side and they
there was a picture showing the
babysitter with the Hawks that's family
nine nine month old daughter Alexandra
at the asphalt green playground and then
the post was secretly shared with
another Facebook group of 36,000 members
of us Mama's blessing so it the caption
was this nanny kept the baby tied in a
stroller for two hours and her older
sister Arya unattended at the playground
today please tell their family so
there's a group that will catch nannies
being bad nannies
Mandy Watchers yeah
and I was a baby and this child for two
hours okay so then the family is like oh
no they were sleeping this is crazy so
the picture that the the facebook chat
was supposed to the facebook chat was
also the same exact picture that the
nanny had sent to the family showing
like oh the baby's taking a nap right oh
yeah and so but they still like you they
wanted to give benefit of the doubt so
this babysitter had been with them for
more than a year and they loved this
babysitter and they confronted
confronted her and the babysitter was
like was like I I would never neglect
your girls like that the baby was
sleeping and then the other one was
never like unattended she was running
around like right in front of everybody
like right in front of her eyes and
wasn't on her phone or anything and she
just felt really sad and like I felt
like she wasn't being trusted and so
then the family got pissed so they go on
for that who the Facebook person at the
Facebook group yeah they get pissed
because on there they're just like tons
of comments are like how dare she laughs
what the [ __ ] like I would fire her
immediately oh I'm never hiring her if I
ever see her I'm gonna confront like the
worst people you can right and they
don't even know this person they just
are filling in the blank just need a
judge oh it's from the place negatively
yeah because their lives are miserable
deep burn like you could fill in the
blanks positive yeah but you choose but
you choose not to I choose never to
people don't give benefit of the doubt
anymore especially to strangers [ __ ]
strangers yeah they're like Oh shitty
people have [ __ ] me over in their past
well everyone's shitty if I don't know
you and I don't know your character then
you must be shitty which is a weird
concept it is a thing that happens with
humans it's like they did this study
where like if you don't know the full
story of something your brain needs to
fill in the holes so it'll just fill in
gaps and then your brain actually
believes that that's what I realized how
nice the world was when I started
selling things on ebay and shipments
weren't going to their house and then I
would email back and say sorry we had a
delayed
shipment and they would say if that's
okay and I'm like I totally lied to you
but you're nice so you're the shitty
person
I was the shitty person and I'm like wow
the world is such a trusting place and
then the shipment didn't come because I
didn't buy it and I forgot to get that
item and I sold it before I had the item
in my possession and it eventually got
to their place a month later and I
realized the world is such a great place
there's such a forgiving place they are
asked for it I am asking if it's given
and that's why I'm like man that's why I
think everyone's shitty cuz I'm [ __ ]
I see what it is you are so if you've
been a benefit of the doubt it's because
you you're think of yourself as a good
person with good intentions
so you give benefited out everyone else
but I had this manager that sued me
because he thought I was doing shady
[ __ ] because he's a shady [ __ ] all the
time and he thought I was like had this
agenda and all kinds of worked out and
then he like because he's like I better
get you before yeah she gets me yeah
yeah she's gonna be a gold digger yeah
oh so anyway this got really nasty on
the Facebook group and like it got kind
of racial people were calling her a hood
rat and like people were criticizing her
long painted dirty nails oh I have a
question so who started all of this so
this how did they get a picture of her
they were at the park and they took a
picture of it and they over her and then
like the baby and everything so she was
in the picture she's next to the
stroller yeah did she ask them to cuz
you said that it's the same picture that
she sent to yeah it was nearly an
identical picture so it was like the
nanny sent a picture of the baby
sleeping yeah and then some other girl
can't woman came by and took a picture
of the baby sleeping oh but she made her
own assumptions she was like oh my god
yeah yeah but it's no so baby was by
itself in the stroller oh wait she
didn't employ faces even she'd employ
the faces of it just sucks there should
be some kind of view for that yeah
that's defamation also it's annoying
because like she's trying to say I care
so much about this child if you cared so
much about that child stand by the child
wait for the nanny to come back ask some
questions but instead she had to put
this through the filter of gratification
took the photo and she said I'm going to
post this to my group and make sure
everyone's outraged with me because if
she cared about the child just solve the
problem
excuse me nanny are you are watching the
kid and the nanny would have been like
the kid sleeping Oh any if you care that
much hang out at the park for 30 minutes
and make sure the child's being taking
all the actual problems she wanted
something out of it and it's like it's
like sure ultimately she wanted the
nanny fired but she added in this extra
kind of padding that was like I'm gonna
get something out of this for myself I'm
gonna use this child to get something
for myself and Lefty yeah because people
were like it takes a village what guys
feeling in the Blake's positively I
think she's she's she was a concerned
citizen yeah and she cared so much for
the baby and so she needed to do her ass
is too stupid to dial nine-one-one
because she forgot the number but she
does remember that she's a part of this
moms group and she took a picture and
she posted it there I think that's what
happens
people are like nannies are getting
increasingly afraid of like getting
these weird pictures taken of them so
they're getting like less more more
hesitant to take work are their 90s that
take care of the kids and also have sex
with the husband's back to them because
they do both because those ones are over
let me tell you about the Jeep cordless
this is where I get heated okay so
they're only calling out like Asian
Mexican and black nanny's rarely ever
those are the best ones showing a white
nanny because I've never seen the white
nanny before unless they're British
yeah cuz they're British like Mary
Poppins it's all like 22 year old white
nannies we need a Sherman Oaks look a
different color then if you have a white
nanny but they don't assume like that
what if that's their parents but if
everyone attacking white is that way no
they're doing the opposite well so they
see a like a black person with a white
kid and they don't ever ask I mean they
as in the people that are attacking them
in the commets are all white I don't
know okay the point I'm making is
they're assuming that's a nanny because
like it's not an adopted child or
and a lot yeah like a lot of them are
that it's actually the mom I [ __ ] love
these loser outside you and they're
miserable you know the funny thing is
too if I see two white parents and a
black kid I'm like that's an adopted
baby I don't think like that's a nanny
or anything I'm like you adopted that
child like where's the other where does
the vice-versa
like come on y'all yeah yeah so this
family they found the original poster
and they got so [ __ ] pissed at her
and so what they did was they found out
where she works where she's like why
they called and they like made sure
which one thing you know where that your
employee tried to ruin the career of
this other individual and they sent out
a bunch of emails and like put her on
blast and they're like you know we don't
know if she got fired or anything but we
feel very satisfied with what people
cause [ __ ] issues like that yeah they
need to taste their own [ __ ] medicine
yeah yeah you know it's funny these
people like okay just like we did that
story before about the chick that called
out the straitjacket they they they go
to this filter of like I will only
receive praise but when they get even
the slightest form of backlash they're
so shocked yeah I think they're so
[ __ ] sure they thought the I mean
they imagine what would happen is
they're gonna be put on this pedestal as
if this brave Savior there are y'all
excited me I'm supposed to be the good
person she's a concerned citizen she's
like I gotta do something here and she
thinks she's like protected by a cause
like whether it be mental health or
protecting children like you want your
own gratification you're hiding behind
just like the other qubit
or like [ __ ] all the Susan's like
they all do that even after the fact she
goes would I do the same thing again
absolutely hands down I make we all need
to look out for each other and keep our
children safe you go this lady she is an
idiot my mom I saw when she was in town
we went to the the bank and we're in the
parking lot and then there's a baby in
the car with nobody in the know so my
mom was livid yeah it's like if this
lady don't come in two minutes I'm
calling the cops
yeah and she stayed by the car and I'm
like I'm like she's trying to solve the
problem yeah
I would have broke all the windows I
want to took a patient put on my
facebook group stupid that sounds in
comparison yeah oh yeah so she started
she started walking up and she was like
my mall started going off with her like
yo you can't leave your kid in the car
I'm gonna call the car park get in the
car put that AC I'll put the window down
I'll call the cops right now she stood
up for her car team weren't even down no
she's like I guess the lady would to go
to the ATM or whatever whatever it was
you try saying like I just go in and out
she's like no I'm calling the cause if
you don't put this [ __ ] windows down a
cor I'm standing right here to get your
[ __ ] I'm like it only takes a few
minutes for that baby to be [ __ ]
opened wait no guys
no it takes a village yeah right take a
picture of the home she doesn't care
about the whole thing
and you know some people just like share
subscribe if you think yeah some people
don't know that if you [ __ ] it and leave
the windows up on a hot day you leave AD
I think that's so stupid yeah but
there's a lot of idiots that don't know
so it's better to just sit there and
explain that to them than to [ __ ] put
them on blast for the world to see
you're already assuming that they're
like hella incompetent to the point
where they're doing it maliciously yeah
a lot of people I just think are just I
think the overall like reality is people
are just stupid and that's the thing
about this you got educate is that the
person taking the picture she didn't
talk to the nanny she didn't confront
the news wasn't like you like to talk to
people your concern
are you gonna are you watching news the
only time you do this is when you see a
crackhead dancing and talking to
themselves that's we should have a whole
Facebook group of that that's when you
record and you don't need to talk to
them you need a comfort if they're
jacking off on the street you could just
record them you don't need to talk to
them and then you put it on the Facebook
group that's what that's what that's the
perfect time to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]